let's talk about the title of your book
the master in its emissary which i
believe is derived from the nietzschean
story
in the nichian story the emissary is
contemptuous of the master
now that has me wondering does the left
hemisphere
have some emotional reason that it
thinks that it
is primal or that it has an emotional
reason to usurp
the right brain because people normally
associate emotion with the right
and the left is just calculating
well it's interesting because all those
things that people used to say
that they're just you know emotions in
one hemisphere that is
entirely wrong as i say what is
different is the way
so they each have emotions they just
have different ways of relating to the
world
and interestingly the emotion that most
lateralizes is anger
and it lateralizes to the left
hemisphere not to the right
it's tempting
and not perhaps entirely wrong since
after all
the brain is part of a person to think
of these two hemispheres as having
personalities of a kind
um i mean of course one immediately
invites the
poster you know the ones answer for more
phrasing
a computer or something but of course
one's easy easily sort of
skewing the picture by thinking of the
brain as a computer because it's
obviously part of a living person as
well anyway
um to cut a long story short yes
when when you isolate one hemisphere at
a time
the left hemisphere is more confident
even when it's entirely wrong
and tends to increase its sense of
conviction when it's presented with data
that suggests that it might be wrong
whereas the right hemisphere
tends to be more um more open to
well it might be something different
ramachandran you know
very well known neuroscientist says um
that he calls it the the um
the devil's advocate the right
hemisphere because well the left
hemisphere is jumping to conclusions
which it does
very quickly the right hemisphere is
going yes but on the one hand and on the
other
and you know another element that we
miss very much in today's
culture is that ability to nuance
physician opinions and see this good and
bad in many things
that more and more of something you
think is good is not necessarily good
and so forth
but to come back to the hemispheres
it's also true that the left hemisphere
sees less i mean it literally sees less
uh in the sense of it attends to less
and therefore takes in
less of the world and when you see or or
understand less you think you know it
all
there's uh a phenomenon in psychology
called the dunning-kruger effect
which basically is that when people are
very bright they think they don't know
very much
but when they're stupid they think they
know everything and so it's the people
who are
at least intelligent who are most
dogmatic
about their views and i think that
you could say that the left hemisphere
suffers from not really understanding
jumping to conclusions and tending to be
rather impatient and angry
um so yes i think you could you could
say that about them and what
what i've been amazed by is in how many
cultures
there is a story like the master in his
emissary
of two brothers or
an emperor and his general or whatever
it is
these two powers and one of them is
clearly
sort of superintendent of the other but
the
the other thinks that it should be the
master
even though it doesn't really understand
what it's doing and it
tries to resist and even to try to
destroy
that force now that that story exists in
iroquois
legends it exists in chinese
8th century literature you know it's
it's there
all around the world it's there in inwit
mythology
what is this that we're seeing i think
it is an understanding
that there is a part of us that is
somehow unwilling to accept um
that it knows very little
and if only more people einstein
actually said in the letter to the queen
of belgium
he said if more people understood how
very little we know the world would be a
much nicer place to live in
you